i do understand that the church hasn't
always been the best place because
of um
they take the sin of homosexuality and
they put a crown on it and actually
every sin needs to have a crown on it
because you know god doesn't accept any
sin
what's the contrast between christianity
and the lgbtq culture find out on this
episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us today at led live i have a
special guest with me wayne blakely
we've been doing a couple shows with him
and he's been teaching us a lot about
just some of the things that are going
on in the world revolving around this
whole lgbt culture and how it's shaping
and shifting our society and things like
that and it's been really awesome to
have you on the show a couple times so
thanks mikey yeah thank you for have
thank you for being on and today we're
going to actually go in and find out
where this all happened in your life how
this started and and we're just going to
hear your testimony so
i i'd love to get into it like when did
this start in your life like at what age
were you when you felt like you
identified as what homosexual bisexual
well you know that's kind of a funny
question because
i didn't really know what was going on
i was young
you know very young you know i had a
birth mother who carried me throughout
her pregnancy
adamant that she was going to give birth
to a girl and not a boy so she had no
she'd already met up her mind you know
she wasn't gonna love me if i was a boy
wow so i was clearly born a boy um i
guess that's questionable in today's
society but what is a boy but
anyway um my dad was in the air force
and and he wasn't on base very much and
so as i began my life began to shape
by the time i was two and a half years
old
my birth mother had broken my arm in two
different places
why what was the question
well nobody really knows because they
weren't around wow other than the fact
that she didn't like boys well yeah
that's me with with my busted arm
so i had a
kind of a brutal awakening of not you
know not being loved and she desperately
wanted a girl not a boy so the imprint
of that happened prenatally and the
postnatal abuse
you know pretty pretty well cinched it
up
but i had a
aunt and an uncle that were christian
that um they ended up permanently
adopting me
and then what age was that i was two and
a half yeah
my birth father came home
uh on travis air force base and noticed
the broken arm and he'd been warned by
neighbors and said hey i think your wife
is abusing your child
and he said
i think you just should mind your own
business you're being nosy neighbors
and
so when he found my arm broken
he asked my mom hey what happened to
wayne and she said oh he has bursitis
and bursitis is like an arthritic
condition i might get at the age i am
today but certainly not at two and a
half years old so he knew something was
up
and so that's when he reached out to his
sisters and his brother that lived in
san diego and
so a um
well my uncle fred and my aunt virginia
they ended up adopting me
and then the the next slide that you
have um shows that at two and a half
years old three years old i'm running
around the house screaming i don't want
to be a boy i want to be a girl
and so you can see very i mean i
gendered dysphoria before they even had
a term for it do you think that came
from the fact that you felt un
you know wanted by your mother yeah i
think that i was desperately trying to
be what she desired so that i could have
get the the love affirmation that i that
i needed and should have had
and you know at this point in in time of
course my aunt and uncle are like
they're not putting all this together i
mean today we can put these things
together but it was hard then to figure
out what was really going on so i tell
people today you know be very careful
when your young child is questioning you
know the fact of their gender
because they could very easily be going
through a phase
that when they're you know
18 years old they may tell you oh shoo
you know i know i'm a guy now but i
wasn't so sure of that when i was a kid
well parents are following through with
gender reassignment surgeries today and
the government's getting involved in the
payment of those
and it's like everything's based on
emotions and on feelings instead of you
know on facts
add the christian element and and of
course we want to live in order to
please god and so switching genders or
um operating
with a with a different narrative like
the cultural narrative today is kind of
dangerous
yeah it's interesting because i i mean i
had a cousin that even at like nine you
know she would act like a dog crawl
around under the table and bark and
stuff and it's like if you're gonna put
the if you're gonna put that in the
hands of the child
i mean what we're gonna do start putting
collars and leashes on that well
unfortunately they actually do that
today but but and yeah it's crazy how
some people act out those things
but most of the time it's adults i think
that are doing that right and that kids
i went to school and from first grade
till 12th i was teased bullied and
harassed um i was effeminate
it was like there was some brand on me
that made me distinctly different than
the other guys and this is like high
school this is from first grade onward
yeah so it was brutal i there wasn't a
day i didn't come home from school that
i wanted to
to be non-existent disappear off the
face of the earth
i didn't know what homosexuality was
um
but
because of not being affirmed and
accepted by
masculine guys on sports teams and stuff
which i didn't have any interest in
sports at all
um
i think that developed a a
a fascination
with you know guys that were what they
were supposed to be right and so there
there became this craving of wanting to
be
affirmed by somebody who was masculine
who would give me
um
value you know some who would want to be
my friend
just out of curiosity your dad was in
the military he somehow got
your uh his
brother and sister or his uh siblings to
get custody of you yeah i don't know how
that played out but that means that he
wasn't in your life anymore or was did
he visit when he came back essentially
so we did keep an ex connection he was
he was my my aunt's brother
and so
we would always go back to like their
homestead where they grew up and so he
ended up remarrying and he would be
there and i would be
you know coming to see him and with my
with my new family and i'd say hey what
do i
how do i refer to him and they said well
i want to just call him daddy morris you
know he was more of an uncle to me than
he was a dad and he was very um
quiet he didn't he didn't really speak
very much he said i'm glad that your
your
your uncle fred and virginia took you i
you know i believe they're taking good
care of you and that was pretty much the
extent of it he was really pretty quiet
even in his own family what about your
mom did you have any my birth mother
yeah actually didn't meet her until i
was 27 years old wow
so she didn't even try to um visit you
she would so they she lived in um
around the washington dc area and we
lived in california
and so she would call on the phone
and i would answer
but my aunt and uncle who i always refer
to as my parents now they would say
it's interesting she would call you
would answer the phone and they would
ask to talk to us when when she could
have very easily checked out you know
how you were doing and you know those
kinds of things so you had to felt like
rejection from your parents and now
you know
friends
yeah it was it was a mess
and
so my you know my parents are now
watching me grow up
dealing with this bullying and harassing
i have interest in
flowers and in design and things like
that and not doing the the masculine boy
things which was really
heavy and important you know and then
as i adopted into this family
my cousins became my brother and my
sister so my new brother is seven years
older than me and now he's got this
effeminate little kid running around it
was it was embarrassing to him it was
challenging for him and we didn't bond
well at all what what drew you to those
girly type things because you did now
you have like a father figure in the
home
you had a brother
uh
was were you drunk was it the things
that you saw your your mother figure
doing or what what do you think drew you
to those i think that the impress
had been so
had been strongly indented on me on my
birth mother that it it didn't matter
that i was in a new environment
it did the damage had already been done
right and
that you know that
impress upon me that you you're
not supposed to be a boy you're supposed
to be a girl and nobody really knows the
conversations and the things that she
was saying to me for the two and a half
years before anybody else got involved
and i think that
those are the years that are supposed to
be bonding years and so if you're
already rejected by a parent telling you
that you're supposed to be something
else
that that's
you know that was a difficult time
um in
about the seventh eighth grade
there were people that we would go
camping with
and they had two boys that were
classmates of mine
they introduced me into sex into
masturbation and i thought oh okay i'm
not i am normal
because i i didn't think of it any other
way i just thought all of a sudden this
affirmation was taking place and it was
like oh i couldn't wait to go camping
every time we went camping there was
this sexual exploration
homosexual with them bogus that's what
you'd call it so are they homosexuals no
so that's what that was gonna tell you
next was the interesting thing
is that within two years they were both
saying i don't want to do that anymore i
have a girlfriend
and so i'm like oh okay so i'm probably
going to get a girlfriend anytime soon
and i'm thinking well lord i'm i'm
waiting and yet when i would meet girls
and stuff there were no fireworks that
went off there was no
i i didn't feel what other guys they
have interest in you and you didn't have
interest in them or was it kind of yes
yeah there were girls that were
you know
they knew that i wasn't a popular boy
but there were some that were just nice
and they thought
you know let me get to know this guy
well getting to know them was
um
just wasn't satisfying for me and
and i i i was thought i was trying to do
what i was supposed to do but the bells
and the whistles weren't going off right
kind of just going through the motions
but you weren't feeling it it wasn't you
right
yeah so
um
i knew then and because i was reading
the bible and it said you know talked
about all the places where homosexuality
was mentioned
that god you know didn't condone those
relationships
and so i knew that that was wrong
but i didn't even identify myself
identifying myself as homosexual at that
point i knew i was leaning that way but
i didn't have any confirmation of that
till i was 18 years old
and
i was working for loma linda university
one night this orderly
tells me you should
talk to my roommate on the phone
so i called him and he
says oh he says
you're gay
and i was like what what's that
that you know with this way back
many years ago
and it was when
gay was just being introduced into
society and he's i said what does that
mean and he said um you like guys don't
you
and i said um
it's starting to look that way he said
well why don't you come over when you
get off work
so i did and he lit up a joint was the
first joint i'd ever had and
uh
then he told me that um christianity
breeds homosexuality
and so this guy is a christian or yeah
he's going to a christian school or
something yeah yeah he says i said wow
where do you get that idea he said well
you're gay i'm gay i go to a christian
college with other guys that are gay he
says the church does a great job of
telling us that homosexuality is sin
and then they don't say anything else
they don't tell you about how to escape
what you're supposed to be doing instead
of what's the solution yeah no no
nothing that would draw you into a realm
of of solution of what god's answers
were and so i said you know what i think
you're right
and so i said um well he said i'll take
you to your to your first gay bar
so he took me to my first gay bar and
i instantly thought i was like in heaven
guys were coming up to me hey what's
your name what are you doing next
saturday night we're having this party
we're going to go camping do you want to
go with us and all of a sudden guys are
also wanting to meet me and go to bed
with me
and
this is how i know the devil twists
things because
all of a sudden i'm getting being
introduced to a life that i wasn't
familiar with
so
i was a nobody i was
stinking you know and all that stuff
and now all of a sudden people are
wanting to get acquainted with me
and but you're fun and friendly
where where you guys been
and so you know the idea of sex and
drugs and drinking
i abandoned everything that i was taught
that was wrong and went down this road
and
um
it was
it was pretty dangerous i had um
you know before aids there was there
were a lot of people that were getting
hepatitis
from sexual encounters and and so i got
hepatitis twice
both times hospitalized
nearly lost my life
and
yet it didn't
have any uh
effect on me that i would leave
you know the culture and come to christ
right and
so
essentially i would spend the next 40
years in the lgbt
uh culture
and
i um
i ended up moving to key west florida i
went i lived all over the place i lived
in san francisco and uh
key west florida i call sodom by the sea
because
it was in those days and it was it was
the whole island was basically gay and
you just about got off the airplane and
they would give you lines of cocaine
and even the police were doing lines of
work cocaine
key west key west florida yeah the the
cops even did lines of coke off of off
of the bars
and so it was just a life that was
totally influenced for the senses
you know i ended up working in the um
tourist industry
and again coke was done by my room
service manager coke was done by his
manager i mean it was like everybody was
was out of it
and
in the early 80s came
aids
and
[Music]
there wasn't any
at the time there wasn't any test for
aids but they begin to screen to see
what people uh what their sexual
encounters had been
and if they were candidates for actually
getting aids
and the odd thing was that it didn't
have much impact on us uh for for me and
my friends we still we
we we didn't use all uh some of us
didn't use protection and we just were
like early twenties or something i was
thirty and then by the time i was yeah
it seems like you asked there's like a
certain time in your life when you just
kind of feel invincible like man i don't
know nobody with that stuff like it's
not gonna yeah kind of pretty safe or
whatever right then
it was like nobody was gonna nobody was
gonna stop this is how addictive the
culture was because nobody was going to
stop having fun and engaging in the
practices that we were i think today
there's probably less promiscuity i'm
not sure
because i'm not in the culture so much
today
but um i'd like to remind people today
that that lgbt culture wasn't founded in
a church and christ wasn't the center of
the lgbt culture you know it came about
gay rights came about in a in a gay bar
in stonewall in new york city and it was
from wanting to get together and hook up
and drag queens going to that bar and a
demonstration of our rights but there
was an involvement of jesus and so today
the idea of a gay christian doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense to me
because you take the the
the label or the term gay which says
this is a person who prefers intimate
relations with someone of the same
gender
christian so i'm like wow who just got
dethroned i mean
you know it was all about
sensuality before they even said the
name of christ right and
i
i had praying parents and i do believe
in the power of prayer because i think
that when you don't pray for somebody
um that gives over more more power to
just really suck them into the world and
into the plans of the enemy
sometimes it's kind of hard to
comprehend you know because we have free
will but i know that in my personal
testimony i always have to share that my
mom always prayed for me and that and
that her testimony really had an impact
in my life even though at the time
i hated even hearing her talk about it i
made my skin crawled want to leave the
room here we go this jesus stuff
but now i can't even share my testimony
without sharing hers and the fact that
she prayed always for me and
i'm going through things in my life now
that god's teaching me the the power of
intercessory prayer
and that
you know in ezekiel before god brought
judgment he said he was looking to see
if anyone was standing in the gap and
found none so he was looking for someone
that was praying for this lost city
and didn't find anybody praying for him
and i was like wow that's so powerful to
think about that
if someone was praying for that city
he might not have brought judgment just
like
when moses was praying for the
israelites while he's on the mountain
and it says that god repented of this
wicked thing he thought to do and how
lot or
abraham prayed for a lot and his family
and they got pulled out of sodom and
gomorrah
and so yeah i'm learning the
the real power of an accessory prayer
it's still hard to figure out like how
it all works but i believe in it you
know i tell people
today
you know we we don't tell god what to do
but we give him our requests and our
desires and then it's in god's timing
and it's up to the to the person and
the
being receptive to the holy spirit you
know and and that's why sometimes
prayers take a long time to get answered
because often people have to hit rock
bottom before they can actually hear god
speaking to them you know we try all
these things that we think is going to
work we use human reasoning and
then rely upon the
uh
the the knowledge of others instead of
taking god at his word and then we find
out oh this is not working
and then we realize that we need a
higher power we need jesus so after all
this rejection and you find this
community where you feel like man i'm
somebody and you're
you're partying and stuff are
is it really bringing you fulfillment or
are you just kind of escaping from
well interesting that you would say that
i was
the you know through the drugs and the
alcohol hollywood's looking for the
escape you know numbing the pain that
that was really underneath all that
and then
i'd always been told that i gave um
great massages and so i saw that there
was this whole
community
that
was involved in
erotic massage so basically the escort
business or
erotic massage business nothing short of
prostitution
and i got involved in that um
interestingly i didn't um
i wasn't seeking so much gay men as i
was heterosexual men and i placed my ads
strategically in strategic places
because you know under the influence of
of drugs and alcohol there were a lot of
men that would just want to try
something new
and they would give me a call to me
it was kind of a back atcha thing it was
like a feather in my cap is how i saw
that because i thought these are the
people these were the people that in the
church or on the school playground or in
their lives that made fun of me now i
know the true colors that they really
aren't any different than i am and it's
so it was a retaliatory kind of
satisfactory thing but deep in my heart
i was hoping that i would run into that
man that would
offer me love and affirmation and
and give me
you know everything that i could
possibly want which essentially
can't be done right
because it's not it wasn't god's will
and god's plan to begin with we can we
can
counterfeit things which is what i
believe satan is up to is counterfeiting
everything he can
and that he can bring a certain level of
satisfaction to people
to to work as a as a and
kind of an anesthetizing agent
and yeah they could be potentially happy
in life
but not have the full
fulfillment of life because again
they're we haven't chosen god we've
chosen self over god and we've chosen
the counterfeit of the enemy and what
he's doing
um it had consequences it definitely had
consequences i was arrested twice and
yeah for prostitution
as the uh erotic masseuse yeah
and then i i faced an erotic massage is
legal but if it goes beyond a certain
point it's like were you set up was it a
i was sat up a cop that you were
massaging yeah i was a group of cops
yeah
so they set it up in a motel and had me
come to take care of two men
and uh they tried to trap me in a lot of
stuff in fact i could tell because there
were a couple of baseball caps that were
sitting on top of the lamps in the in
the hotel room and typically you
wouldn't see guys doing that it looked
very it looked very heterosexual to me
and i was like this is interesting
so they would try to get me to say what
i was going to do
and you know i just said that it was
you know i practiced
safe sex and that i wasn't
you know i wasn't playing fully into
what they were saying but they they kept
waiting and
and finally
you know there was a guy on a bed and
there was a guy sitting
at the little table you know where i'm
sitting on one side there's the lamp and
then there's him sitting on the other
side and he finally gets up acts like
he's heading to the bathroom comes back
turns around paces kind of walks back
towards me and flips this i'm sure they
shine that badge before they flip it
because it was like a searchlight and he
said you know you're under arrest for
prostitution
and he said you're number five and
number six is on the way so it was a
sting
they opened the door to the to the
adjoining room and there was a lady in
there who was you know typing
on a laptop and taking the case
histories putting them in to the
computer
and the five or six men that were in
that room that one of them cuffed me and
they had bottles of booze all over the
place and i was like well i didn't even
know cops could drink on the job but
these guys were
and then they started lecturing me about
aids and that i was causing aids and all
kinds of stuff
i was i was convicted uh it's on my
criminal record uh permanently um
so that was
that was uh yeah these were
you know rough years it didn't stop me i
went right back into it
and uh unfortunately my life hasn't been
very disciplined
um and
even to people today that come to christ
there's a there is often failure and you
know my life ended up as such i've
experienced such but i do believe that
that christ doesn't give up on us and
that um
he offers grace and forgiveness i
often see that the people that give up
on us don't maybe have
that true connection to christ
themselves because
it seems like everybody has something
that they
hang on to a little bit
so
you get in all these like rock bottoms
but you're still not
changing what what point did it get to
where you're just like i'm done with
this yeah i mean
all my friends are dying and
i remains
from aids yeah all of them
and i'm sitting one day in the comfort
of my own bedroom and in front of my
computer and
and
it was really strange
because i
began to contemplate life and what i
knew having been raised as a christian
and i went wow i know how all this ends
that if i continue to live life the way
i'm living it
there is no ever after for me
so i said you know i think i said out
loud god what do you want from me
and the instant response that i got was
intimacy
and i went
okay that's
that's interesting because god courts us
he does everything he can to get our
attention but once he has our attention
do we court him did we spend time with
him do we get to know him i mean how
much does a person really know about
christ
and because he says that that he only
intends good for me not harm he knew me
before i was born all these things begin
to float back into my mind
and i thought well
maybe i should have a look at this
and so i typed into my computer
looking for a ministry
that would be
by the church that would be pointed
towards me
and
there really wasn't one from the church
but there was
a lady who was a christian who was a
believer
who was helping people find their way
out
of homosexuality she offered
like four options and the fourth option
said that god
knows your pain your hurt your isolation
he understands what you're going through
but if you will choose him and abide in
him and live in agreement with him you'd
have eternal life with him
and i thought
that sounds appealing to me
i think that that i'd like to know more
about
jesus and you know it had been many
years and so i went and i grabbed a book
called the uh the desire of ages
and i began to read about the ministry
of jesus to humanity and i saw how they
didn't like him
even though he offered them the best
love there is
and
i found myself
praying
you know at the foot of my bed and
i um
i asked god
if he could forgive me for
what i had done to him
and i couldn't believe that
that he essentially could forgive me but
as i had been studying and i found that
the blood of jesus was for that he'd
lived his life for me and done what i
couldn't do myself
so that i could have forgiveness for
for my sins
wow so all this time you never had
people trying to witness to you or share
the gospel just no and i think still
today people don't even know how i'm
still i'm teaching
people today in 12 after 12 years of
ministry 12 years after my conversion
still how to reach out with love and
compassion
without compromise right
and
just like jesus it's like people think
they're going to catch it you know
or they feel like if you
involve yourself with somebody or
befriend somebody who's lgbt
that you have to do what they're telling
you have to agree with what they're
saying and actually lgbt uh culture
today is mandating that unless you agree
with them you don't love them
and that's you know that's it you know
that's warped you know because we are we
all should have the freedom to think how
we think and it doesn't mean that you
that you don't love somebody if you
don't agree with their
their behavior
[Music]
one morning i found myself at the foot
of the bed
sobbing and praying to god because i
said i was looking for forgiveness from
god and i was like
i've led a ton of men down the wrong
road telling them hey you know this is
just natural that you feel this way
there's nothing wrong with it same thing
happened to me
and that i was normalizing what god
you know basically couldn't normalize
and or condone and
what came to my mind was that already
what i was reading was
how this was why god
why jesus came and lived a life without
sin
so that he could offer his life for me
and shed his blood for me so that he
could actually offer me forgiveness
not to keep sinning but to help me look
to him and walk with him and to see
that his ways were
were better than my ways
because i'm all the you know i didn't
find eternal happiness in lgbt culture
and i actually didn't know
people i knew people that were maybe
sort of satisfied with their
relationships but to say that they had
this
peace and joy in their life
i didn't see it it wasn't there and i
had met thousands you know of of those
who identify as lgbt
i do understand
that the church hasn't always been the
best place because
of um
they take the sin of homosexuality and
they put a crown on it and actually
every sin needs to have a crown on it
because you know god doesn't accept any
sin so which is part of my my um
goal today is to help people learn to
to show love and compassion
to lgbt people and to reflect christ to
them you know in ways that will attract
them to him
that morning it was a saturday morning
and i peeked out of the shower curtain i
looked at the clock and it said 20
minutes to 11 and i thought
there's a church three three miles down
the road from me i'm i'm gonna go to
that church wow and so i walked in
and
you know people were good they were nice
and they're friendly i took a bible with
me i hadn't opened for 35 years and a
friend of mine had given it to me
how old were you i was uh
so let's see 12 years ago i was i was
50.
no wait a minute i was 56
wow
yeah never too far gone man
no so
i even talked about it today when you
spent that much time living
really in in
drastic opposition to the gospel because
my
flesh and the gospel are at direct
opposition with each other
it you know it leaves scars on you and
and you have to deal with those things
because the devil comes chasing you and
he wants you back
and so i
i ended up in
this church for three months before i
even mentioned anything to my parents or
to to my the rest of my family
and you know finally one day i i gave
them a call and said hey um i'm being
re-baptized and
oh
they were
like wow how they just you know they
were elated because they had been
praying all this time
and um
so now
you know they
they were able to see the what god had
done and they were also able to witness
because i decided you know i couldn't be
silent about this
and that i wanted to help other people
recognize that god has truly something
great to offer them
and so i've been in 12 years of ministry
and
how did that come about i mean
it was because within the first year
actually within the first six months
i was already writing articles six
months into my conversion
because i knew that the church didn't
understand what i had been through they
didn't understand themselves what
conversion was and i mean a conversion
of the heart
where somebody comes and gives their
life to christ it the solution for
for the lgbt person is no different than
that of the adulterer or the thief or
the murderer whomever else it's about
surrendering self and abiding in christ
and
when i recognized these things i thought
well i'm i want to become a voice that
offers hope and help
and so the church wasn't doing anything
so i began a website
because it is a small community it makes
up five or six percent of the population
whereas you know people who are doing
adultery or
drugs and alcohol there's a higher
percent of people so there's a lot more
people that can relate to that kind of
culture or lifestyle but
yeah it could be difficult for somebody
who's just i've never had that you know
i've never had that desire i've never
been tempted by right homosexual
i think the numbers are higher it's
estimated at 10 percent but i think it's
actually higher than that because people
don't confess yeah how many people are
going to raise their hand and say hey
that's me
um
we we'd like to downplay it and even in
christianity today like in our church
it's estimated that two percent of the
denominational population
is lgbt i think it's higher
and and my question is because there is
no outreach
corporately
um
do
the rest of the
the leadership in our church think that
the lgbt lgbt population is collateral
for heaven like somebody's gotta
die so when it comes to the end and not
everyone's going to make it to heaven so
we'll just leave them in that pool
you know i did i you know and yeah and
yet the lgbt person is is not usually
i'm on board with what i have to say
either so i'm caught in the middle
between all of this because i want to
offer hope and then there's people out
there here that are not offering hope
and i and i still believe that in the
end it's god's word that is true amen
and so we can't
i can't afford to be bitter about what
the church isn't doing i need to go
forward in what god is commissioning me
to do
to help others understand that there is
this great love and this great sacrifice
that he made for us and he's just asking
us to surrender
sexuality well our whole hearts to him
and and want to please him instead of
ourselves and that's a
it's a very strange concept for
people who have been immersed in the
lgbt
um
ideology so in ministry you've probably
seen a lot of people
have conversions and things but in your
own life was it was it just
overnight change and never went back
never fell no
well i would say the this the first
four years with god was a honeymoon
um i didn't even i didn't even
participate in masturbation in that
whole time
and that was a breath i mean that was a
brash change for me i don't even know
how
because i haven't had four years clean
without that right and so i i often say
to god i want that honeymoon back with
you
um and it is
it's how the enemy operates again the
scars that he left you know on my life
uh for having indulged in things that i
didn't need to indulge in
it's about you know satisfaction
pleasuring the flesh is
it is a difficult thing to conceive
and you know people like to say today
well you're old and irrelevant and so
you don't even know what it's like and
i'm like
no that's not true so uh it is a battle
and a fight but you know the the battle
belongs to jesus
and and we all have our struggles you
know there's probably a lot of people
that were
addicts or alcoholics or whatever they
gave their hearts to god and at some
point they they fell and went back into
that and
you know that's probably a little bit
to the to the world or to the
you know the church they probably kind
of overlook it a little bit easier than
going falling back into homosexuality
like you said it's like this crowned
symbol
so was there any kind of repercussions
or backlash that i just like is there
any kind of hope you can give somebody
that's struggling with that yeah i think
the
the backlash was i lost my position with
coming out ministries
in the ministry that i'd helped co-found
and
and i think that in itself was something
that the enemy thought he could keep me
away from god
and i spent time you know on the sofa i
call it the year and a half on the sofa
because i was trying to figure out what
do i do
what because i didn't stop believing in
god in his ways i simply had failed him
but because of his grace and his
goodness
and because of like proverbs 24 16 that
tells me a righteous man follows seven
times
but that god doesn't give up on you and
if you sin you have an advocate with the
father amen um i was very blessed to
have my dad um after my conversion for
12 years that were the best 12 years
now this is your dad and our air force
no no this is good you know because this
is the christian thing right because i
only had that dead for two years so when
i was adopted this became my dad this
was my uncle that became my dad this is
the one that's been praying for you for
the years yeah for 40 years and so it
was a blessing to come back and to have
a
united relationship with him he came
became my rock on earth
and um i actually i lost him to covet
last september i'm sorry yeah yeah and
he would
let's see he was
yeah then he was 98 would have been 99
this year
in february but he was he was more with
it than i am and he didn't have dementia
or anything like that and so i was very
blessed to have him in my life my god
preserved him long enough to see your
conversion i believe so cause that's a
that's a pretty old age yeah yeah and he
would you know i would go whenever i
would go out on ministry trips he would
always pray for me and tell me that he
was really so happy about what god was
doing in me and through me and
and it was good to have his standard of
hope there and he was
you know he was the perfect christian he
he just really
was humble and meek and um
you know if there were saints you know
he certainly made up
what i would consider to be a saint in
my in my eyes so this is a book
available on my website uh know
hislove.org it's mentioned there what
this book does the guiding families book
goes at this from the idea that we need
to incorporate homosexuality into the
church
and that we need to let people be how
they are and not suggest that change is
possible well
the change again is not about becoming
heterosexual but allowing god to bring a
change of the heart
to a person to live in agreement with
him
and so i was
i wrote this book and i included
seven testimonies from my own
denomination and 14 testimonies of
others outside of the denomination to
show that this is a universal you know
faith issue rather than a just a
doctrinal issue
so the book you're referring to is kind
of like accepting of lgbt uh christian
lgbt and this is kind of like uh it goes
back it is a biblical analysis of the
guiding families book so it says well
here's what guiding family says but
let's look at scripture and see if we
can make the that application or should
we make a a more clear application
according to what the scripture says so
you go to different churches people can
invite you to go
to any denomination that wants to have
the discussion um about
the word homosexuality in the church or
lgbt culture in the church
and so yeah there are multiple
presentations that i do over the course
of a weekend
and
it helps um
all people who are already believers
recognize how they can reach out and
love and compassion to the lgbt
community most people have somebody in
their family identifying as lgbt yeah
those uh you know those numbers that we
said they're kind of small and maybe
they're under numbered but that number
is growing especially among the youth
and yeah you know the older people have
a hard time connecting with the youth as
it is and especially with topics like
this so i mean this is super relevant
and there's not a lot of ministries that
are talking about this so this is great
that you're doing this and so your
ministry is know his love ministries i
love that title because that's what it's
all about man when i sat down to choose
a name for the ministry i thought long
and hard about it and i thought the
whole goal of the ministry and the whole
purpose of the ministry was to get
people to know his love
not a redefined love as as humans try to
put in place but one that says that
god's love was enough and that
and that we can come into a relationship
with him of honor and glory and
obedience towards him
and
interestingly
when you give your life to christ
and decide to live for him amazing
things begin to happen that you never
would have anticipated that's so true
that's what happened in my life you know
when i surrendered everything to him he
was able to open up doors that i never
dreamed he would be able to open up in
my life so it's all about surrendering
to him yeah well wayne thank you so much
for sharing your testimony it's been an
encouragement i mean i i love hearing
that nobody's too far gone me i was
gothic you were in the homosexual
lifestyle and
probably a lot of the christian church
wouldn't even talk to us they'd be
afraid to share their
faith with us you know but
this is something that's on the rise i
mean we see this lifestyle as getting
really popular the media is glamorizing
it and so those numbers are rising and
if you know anyone and your family and
your circle of friends that's struggling
with this you know this is a video that
you could share with them and wayne has
an awesome ministry you can invite
him to your church to do some
presentations he has a lot of good
resources the link is in the description
this is know hislove.org and we just
thank you so much for joining us and we
look forward to seeing you guys next
week don't forget to like share and
subscribe to this channel and we'll see
you guys next week god bless
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world
and in 1999 a movie titled the matrix
hit the world stage these stories are
often told and seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
you